Real quick the state model l of t for
location.
So, you can use just x and
y if you think it's just translating.
You can use the similarity transform
which is x y rotation feta and a scale,
that would be four parameters.
Or you might do a affine defamation if
you're going to allow things to skew
a little bit.
It doesn't really matter.
You just have to have some model and
some way of saying I'm going to be
able to represent these elements.
What's my dynamics model?
Well my dynamics, dynamics model that
they use was actually very simple.
They said, and this is just written P
of L1, given L0, you could write it as
T plus 1 given T, but then I gotta
write all these T plus 1s, all right?
And what you see here is
a bunch of independent
normal distributed variables, right?
So, what this says is that the x value
is just normally distributed about
the old x value, with some standard,
with some variance, sigma squared x.
Same thing with the y.
Same thing with the theta.
Same thing with the scale.
So this is a similarity transform.
What is says,
is nothing about how I move an X tells
me anything about how I moved a Y.
That's pure Brownian motion.
So that can be illustrated like this,
right?
So here's Lt, this is where I think
the thing was at anytime t and
what this Brownian motion says well Lt
plus 1, maybe I'm right near by, maybe
I'm at the same place but, oriented
differently, maybe I'm over here,
maybe I'm over there, maybe I'm
over there, maybe I'm over here.
With a likelihood of being
in any of those locations
depends upon how far I've moved.
That's what these things here say.
Okay.
So in other words, moving further away
from my old Y gets less and less likely.
What you can do is you can imagine
distributing a whole bunch of
possibilities, and that's what's
illustrated here is Lt plus 1.
And, the idea is that the farther Lt
plus 1 is from L, from Lt, in terms of
x, y, theta and scale or any of the
other variables, the less likely it is.
So that's our dynamics model.